une partie des défenses du chrétienne
pour la ville de kharkiv sont situés là
bas cela dit les ces frappes sont aussi
incertaine imprécises hier et encore il
ya eu une explosion c'est une partie de
l'après midi avec une brigade de
secouriste qui se déplaçait en ambulance
afin de porter secours aux blessés et
nous sommes allés avec eux en milieu
d'après-midi vers le secteur de ses
actifs qui hack est l'un des quartiers
les plus pilonné dans le nord de la
ville tiens donc nous sommes arrivés là
il ne s'agissait pas de frapper rn2
frappe donc de la de l'armée de l'air
russe de jet russe il s'agissait de tirs
semble-t-il de missiles grad donc il
s'agit de lance-roquettes multiples
extrêmement imprécises meurtrier
surnommés les orgues de staline qui
frappait régulièrement kharkiv donc sauf
d'arriver dans ce secteur de ses actifs
canne dans mon découvert une tonne de
scènes de guerre en milieu urbain nous
avons en compter au moins trois points
d'impact donc de ces roquettes grad la
première frappe est en tout cas c'est ce
que nous avons vu un grand centre
commercial centre commercial qui était
en feu une impressionnante colonne de
fumée s'élever au dessus du centre
commercial les pompiers étaient à la
manoeuvre pour voilà peut-être
entendre une série d'explosions en ce
moment même voilà
non donc je reprends sur cette attaque
hier donc le centre commercial était en
feu les taux les pompiers tentaient
d'endiguer ce feu et il nous expliquait
que tous les jours ils interviennent
pour éteindre des feux dans des
bâtiments résidentiels mais aussi dans
des écoles dans des crèches sur des
stations service voilà donc s'il y a
peut-être des objectifs militaires en
tout cas ce que nous disent tous les
gens de car qui sait que ce sont surtout
des zones civiles qui sont régulièrement
bombardée tout le monde ici dénonce
évidemment des infractions au droit
international de la guerre donc nous
sommes arrivés dans ce secteur de satish
cas et les agents les habitants d'un
immeuble qui était tout proche de ce
centre commercial d'ailleurs à préciser
que dans ce centre commercial il y avait
un supermarché une filiale locale du
groupe français auchan nous n'avons pas
confirmation 6 2 ne savons pas pour
l'instant si le champ a été gagné par
l'incendié les habitants ont donc tout
proche était à dans un immeuble qui
venait d'être frappé par l'une ou
l'autre de ces roquettes grad il était
évidemment tous en état de choc toutes
les villes de l'immeuble et du quartier
avaient été soufflées par l'explosion
les secouristes que nous accompagnons
s'activer à
à se courir à soigner les blessés donc
de très nombreux blessés avaient été
avait été taillé par des éclats de verre
ou par divers débris pendant l'explosion
une partie des blessés ont été évacués
vers évidemment vers les urgences qui
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours reçoivent des blessés lors de
cette attaque d'après les autorités
locales il y a eu environ une quinzaine
de blessés et une personne une dame a
été tué